do that guy in my car until he spent  away you saw what he looked like yeah  he's taller dark Carsten like dark hair  kinds like you I guess a little kinda so  he was black  uh yeah that's why this is my friend  jasmine and curly  hi everybody see you but emphasized  enough to see Mary Nana comin atcha  quick passing yo KK yeah cool  so V naught gamma D doctor Lee kept in  uh yo fellas what up let's take a selfie  with it go haha oh look let me change  the filter yeah yeah oh Jesus Mary and  Joseph  what everyone said that grande okay what  anyone ever tell you you look like Aegis  Elba but I'm sure if you go talk to him  to let you slide  oh hell no girl just take that ticket so  you talk to him  why me saying the word re-watch you're  dancing though good song hey yo you  having a good time man yeah I just just  not really feeling the music you know  [Music]